most of all i want to acknowledge the
children
who are terrified
and suffering at this moment
that's angelina jolie tearfully giving
her support for domestic abuse victims
and the many people
for whom this legislation comes too late
the women who have suffered
through this system with little or no
support
who still carry the pain and trauma of
their abuse
during her visit to washington d.c on
wednesday angelina jolie was joined by
her and brad pitt's 17 year old daughter
zahara jolie pitt the mr mrs smith
actress addresses lawmakers about the
senate's renewal of the violence against
women act when there is silence from a
congress too busy to renew the violence
against women act for a decade it
reinforces that sense of worthlessness
you think i guess
my abuser's right
i guess i'm not worth very much
that's why passing
this law is one of the most important
votes
u.s senators will cast this year the
46-year-old mom of six gets emotional
when discussing children who are
suffering most of all i want to
acknowledge the children
who are terrified
and suffering at this moment
the maleficent star also addresses women
who have been victims of abuse the women
who have suffered
through this system with little or no
support
who still carry the pain and trauma of
their abuse
the young adults who have survived abuse
and emerged stronger
not because of the child protective
system
but despite it
and the women and children who have died
who could have been saved
angelina's moving words are met with a
hug
but we're guessing the most important
support came from daughter zahara
you can see the mother-daughter duo
walking hand in hand after the
conference
this isn't the first time ange and
zahara have taken on capitol hill in
december angelina shared this pick with
her daughter showing their efforts to
work with quote advocates and lawmakers
to modernize and strengthen the hashtag
violence against women act to include
protections for children's health and
safety communities of color tribes lgbtq
survivors rural areas and all survivors
not only does ange work hard she and her
family know how to play hard the actress
hit the eternals red carpet with their
kids and spilled on the fun they're
having it's a tiny piece of our life you
know everybody we have
we are we are just a family but this
little piece of our life where this is a
moment
i'm happy that they're able to to have
some fun with it and not take it too
seriously and
and start to explore themselves even
with their fashion
[Music]
you